my anxiety has kept me up for over 50
hours
this was literally the most beautiful
and moving thing that i have ever heard
there there baby boy took all the time
you need hey guys come on
thank you thank you very much
yeah hey
you're right man the toast that you gave
to ben and leslie
was so beautiful and i'm feeling very
raw
from my therapy i was so happy
so sad like a perfect storm of emotions
and so i'm hiding out here so i don't
ruin
this party for my two amazing
best friends who i love so much
oh there's no more tissue
everything ends no no no no there's
there's more tissues
goes away
please open up we have a warrant just
kidding it's us how he got you
andy and april we have someone who wants
to see you
champion come here
you are such a brave good dog so much
spirit
you've overcome so much you are the most
wonderful dog
in the whole world and i am so happy for
you
wow that's amazing see there you go
this one's not as good all right chris
here's the plan
i'm just gonna list off happy things
until you're cheered up
pizza the beach rock and roll music and
i'll list terrible things to bring you
back down
smallpox botched surgery snails crawling
out of your mouth
this is weirdly working it's evening me
out okay keep going keep going laughter
snails crawling out of your mouth the
beach snails crawling out of your mouth
cute cats snails crawling out of your
butt dave matthews band
dave matthews band i no longer trust
anything other than my own two hands
it is debilitating but exciting if i
keep my body moving
and my mind occupied at all times i will
avoid falling into a bottomless pit
of despair i absolutely think that we
should keep campaigning
the worst possible thing we could do
would be to stop because the campaign
stops
we all stop and stopping is certain
death who wants a panini
anyone everyone i'm gonna say everyone
all right
april i just got championed his dog food
cleaned your house
filed that paperwork you are officially
april ludgate dwyer
installed a smoke detector and now i'm
back what's next
nothing chris just sit down somewhere
and stop bothering me
i can't i've had a very tough year
i can't stop thinking about ann and
millicent
and if i'm alone with my thoughts i go
to a dark place
okay first of all dark places are
awesome secondly ann
is kind of lame so way to dodge a bullet
and millicent is jerry's daughter
so two bullets and you're not alone
you've got lots of friends
somewhere i assume
you're gonna be just fine thank you
you're right i'll be fine
i'm not fine it didn't work i am 100
certain that i am zero percent sure of
what i'm going to do
you seem like you're in a good mood
actually i am quite miserable
i admire and respect you and dragging
you through an ethics trial
is filling me with sadness i have never
felt so low well you're radiating pure
joy
i went to my herbalist and got 2v12
shots and then i ate an unreasonable
amount of st
john's wort and my herbalist took this
weird bee pollen paste
rubbed it around my gums and now my
mouth feels like a spaceship
this is stressful and stress leads to
depression and if i don't maintain an
extremely high dosage of herbal remedies
i will get very depressed oh god
it's happening right now
well good news is this is just
tendonitis how is that good news
the other option was shoulder cancer
really no
look you exercise a lot you're in great
shape little things like this happen
with men of your age
man of my age how old do you think i am
42.
i am 44 and i plan to live to be 150.
okay so what's the cure get a time
machine and go back to being 20.
dr harris you are literally the meanest
person i have ever met
it's a battle between my primal desire
to bring a child into this world
and my paralyzing fear of negatively
affecting
any living thing
oh hi ann perkins hi how are you i'm
dying
in the grand scheme of things who cares
we're all just molecules
floating around in random patterns
devoid of meaning
oh my god is inescapable
no no no no no i'm not lonely i have me
and 4 000 facebook friends and a hot
girlfriend i want to find something that
really motivates you why do you want to
achieve this goal
i just want to get a good job for me in
april yes keep going
dick okay yeah uh
i love april i think she's awesome she's
all i care about in the whole world
yes love and family what else is it
really
nothing at all i exercised because when
i was a baby i had a rare blood disorder
and
i suppose i need to feel like my body's
in tip-top shape
so it doesn't destroy me leaving me to
die alone
great you got yours i got mine i'm gonna
go run till i puke let's go
andy repeat after me okay i run for
april i run for april
run for your wife son i run for love i
run for love
plays at your marks what do you run for
again chris nobody
nothing does it really even matter get
set get at me
whoa oh hey you okay no
there's something wrong with my body
what my legs
aren't working i'm broken i need to go
to the hospital and see a doctor right
away
hey man where the doc say everything
okay the
tests and blood work came back and the
news
is terrible they found nothing
nothing nothing the silent killer
oh my god chris that means everything's
okay oh why weren't you at practice this
morning yeah you should have been there
i finally hit my minimum requirement
minimum champion i'm going to die one
day probably
without ever having left my mark on this
silly little planet
i'm gonna die an anonymous
meaningless speck of dust wow
sounds like you're really going through
some tough stuff right now it's too bad
there's not
doctors for your mind all right well
hey i'm gonna go run some more laps will
you time me go
he's kind of right chris you were
freaking out because you were thinking
about andy
and his family and how you don't have
one every time something tiny goes wrong
you spiral like crazy
maybe you should see a therapist
i hope i'm not out of line
oh contraire freyr you are
as inline as a person can be
you are a genius and an amazing
motivator
what was my time i don't know 43
yes new record all my life
i have tried to achieve external goals
run a four-minute mile climb mount
everest
but before i can do that i need to climb
the mount everest of my mind
we both are in serious relationships you
have leslie
and i have my therapist dr richard
nygard who i see 15 times a week
parks department chris trager city
manager friend aspiring life coach
and recipient of dr richard nygard's
award
for most improved patient from my
psychotherapy sessions wow that's great
chris congrats
thanks jerry it's just a piece of paper
and
he only made it for me after i
specifically asked for it while crying
loudly but
it sure meant a lot to receive it if
therapy has taught me anything
it's that i need to face my fears even
when my fears are engaged
to a man with a chiseled jawline of a
young me
dr richard nygard feels that i should
face my fears instead of
running from them he's very wise i see
him five times a week he holds my life
in his hand like a fragile little bird
hey bud hey how are you great i just
finished making an entry in my dream
journal
this time the giant spider got caught
in my web
[Laughter]
progress great idea thank you andy i
agree i love this idea
and i love me for thinking of it my
therapist said that i need to be more
vocal about appreciating myself
thank you chris you're welcome chris i
sound insane
i'm gonna go talk to my therapist
someone in this room has begun
exhibiting symptoms
christopher trager what a few months ago
the thought of an infectious disease
even hypothetical would have sent me
careening towards bummerville but now
i am infected with the killer virus
and i feel fine therapy
i'm afraid i have some very bad news i
chris traeger
after several sustained hours of
diarrhea
combined with violent coughing and a
devastating fever followed by even more
diarrhea
have succumbed to the avian flu
i'm dead
you